Can you zoom in...
Let's take a look at how the shadows are falling...
It just isn't...it's still kind of...
Yeah, we've gotta remember that...
We're lighting for photogrammetry, instead of...
...instead of for a single shot.
So I think we're in good shape.
I like the evenness though, for that.
Yeah, exactly.
So yeah, that's all right for that...
We're doing photogrammetry.
And photogrammetry is essentially taking two-dimensional images and turning it
into three-dimensional data.
So the idea with photogrammetry is that we're
gonna shoot this model in about 200 to 500
images with the camera at different angles.
And what we'll do is triangulate the angles
in software, and we'll come up with a 3D rendering.
If it's done correctly, we'll actually have
an accurate model that's equally accurate to
laser scanning.
But we're just using a regular DSLR camera
and traditional photography principles.
So, it's pretty cool.
So I'm thinking we'll start two thirds off
the end, go this way, convex planar, go this
way, that way, come back planar, this way.
Just work our way as far out as we can on
each side...
So for all of them, just as a dry run, so
what you're saying is so we're gonna start...
Yeah, we'll start right there.
On that line.
And then we're gonna move over, and gonna
do it...
Right there.
Right.
And then lining up so that...
Okay...
Right there.
Right.
And then keep going down the line?
Yep.
Okay...
There we go.
Okay.
All right, so I'm gonna pull the card...
Pull the card so that we're getting...
Well, it looks a little on the mushy side.
Why don't we focus just slightly above the
minimum surface level?
We'll nail our focus about here.
Right.
If it doesn't carry to the tower, then we'll
go back and get pickup shots with...
Of the tower, even after...
Yeah.
...the fact?
So that just means that we can't process all
the files together.
We'll separate out the tower, we'll make it
into a separate chunk, and then we'll realign
that later on.
Okay, we got a plan.
Yeah, makes it a little bit...one more step,
but it's not too bad.
Okay.